si je peux ajouter un mot on n'a pas
parlé il ya un nom qui est pas qu on a
pas dit cmbs ou ryad l'arabie saoudite
parce que là je pense que paradoxalement
les plus embêtés dans l'histoire c'est
peut-être la droite israélienne qui est
au pouvoir la droite de netanyahu parce
que eux ils avaient un grand fantasme
dans la dette un grand espoir c'est
l'arabie saoudite puisque mb s le
nouveau chef de l'arabie saudite là il
est complètement dingue il veut que
l'ennemi absolu c'est l'iran il était
prêt à tout y compris à faire une
alliance avec israël
et là je vois pas enfin je connais mal
l'arabie saoudite de l'intérieur mais je
ne vois pas que le peuple saoudien
accepte ce quelque chose c'est bien sûr
c'est trop trop fort jerusalem sait on
peut pas céder là dessus on peut faire
des échanges de territoires et c'est à
jérusalem donc là je pense que c'est une
grosse connerie de trump qui doit que
danse ou à se mordre les doigts gelés
les israéliens
décalage entre la réalité et les
sentiments et ça a été très très visible
au tournant des années 2000 au moment de
la compétition qui verra jusqu'à
éliminer du premier temps à l'issue du
premier tour et un très fort sentiment
d'insécurité dans le pays avec
l'insécurité première préoccupation des
français
et cette réponse là va se dégonfler en
quelques mois nicolas sarkozy devenu
président ministre de l'intérieur dans
des proportions qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la réalité dure puisque la
délinquance
maintenant les perceptions sont aussi
des faits sociaux du temps dans mon
métier
quand vous avez dans l' enquête qu'ils
aient à rendre publique par le figaro
quarante pour cent des gens qui se
disent dans la sécurité qui disent par
ailleurs ben je fais des détours gentil
apporte au quotidien et si on y
réfléchit bien l'insécurité dans toutes
ses dimensions et une présence
incroyable dans notre vie quotidienne
avec des forts contrastes pour finir
avant de te laisser la parole en trouver
dans les zones urbaines et puis d'autres
zones qui sont
pense pas que
ce chiffre soit très important peut-être
qu'il ya une certaine ce qui serait
ennuyeux pour lui se traite pas être élu
au premier tour contre mais tout ce
qu'on attend enfin je pense qu'il sera
élu au premier tour mais s'il n'était
pas ce serait quand même un signe un
petit peu de difficulté et après après
tout commence pendant quelque temps que
moi je suis de ceux qui croient que même
avec une participation faible
le fait de devenir président du parti
des républicains
même dans un parti dans un assez triste
état va lui donner une légitimité
nouvelle une popularité qui va augmenter
un rôle reconnu deux chefs de
l'opposition et que en plus la
multiplication des digues armand pour
ces voiliers internes le chef de
l'opposition parce qu'il ya mélenchon de
côté qui prétend ceux-là c'est justement
là bas la différence d'autres j'adore
les interruptions non
oui je pense que les égarements de
mélenchon je cherchais un terme très
susceptible de provoquer un déchaînement
limited opa de la part des réseaux
sociaux font qu' il ya un besoin d'une
place il ya un besoin d'opposition il ya
un besoin de quelqu'un pour l'interner
qu assez vite
marine le pen en difficulté mélenchon
erratique
il peut occuper cette platine
maël de calan
[Musique]
et
faisait combien est-ce que ça va être un
dimension laurent wauquiez va devoir
tenir compte ça va dépendre du score de
me répéter mais le rassemblement des
personnes il se fera pas ce qu'il se
fait toujours si ça marche deux côtés de
wauquiez mails de calan viendra à puis
valérie pécresse si ça marche finira par
venir mais vous avez bertrand un beau
jour se dira s'il n'a pas entre temps
été nommé premier ministre par macron or
après tout pourquoi pas donc la grille
de calandre alors c'est moi je pense que
là encore c'est vraiment pas le sujet il
faut éviter d'injurier les gens de les
avoir tous contre soi mais c'est pas la
bataille la bataille très difficile pour
wauquiez s'est réconcilié ce sont ces
électorats de ces crimes en panne il ne
sait pas si les patrons hollandais qui
le soir après on verra
c'est de ne pas faire fuir que vous tous
l'électorat bourgeois modéré prenne pas
ses jambes à son cou pour l'instant il
est quand même très chez makro mais
c'est aussi et je dirais d'abord de
faire revenir lectorat populaire droite
etc qui est partie sous marine le pen
donc et puis ensuite de trouver le
ciment qui va faire tenir tout ça
ensemble banques c'est extrêmement
difficile mais je pense que le problème
même si mal de cadeaux a plein de
qualités de ces races et pas mal de
câlins ou pierre ou paul ou jacques ou
leur force mentale